où
est ce qu'il faut
en mai
oh
mon dieu
m
[Musique]
bah alors énormément de gens ont vu à
cette vidéo
gi oh ça va trop loin elle est
catastrophique cette vidéo déjà parce
que alors du dip fake on ne sait plus ce
qui est vrai et ce qui est pas vrai il
ya plein de gens qui ont dans ces images
ça a été annoncé mort mais il ya plein
de gens ça fait peur aux joueurs
excentrés climat anxiogène et ensuite je
trouve ça extrêmement maladroit comme
manière de communiquer c'est pas parce
qu'un pays connaît l'horreur qu'il faut
imaginer l'horreur dans un autre pays
avec un ton limite menaçant à ses toits
de sous-entendus on nous chante mais
c'est quoi que ce soit si vous ne vous
aider voilà ce qui va vous arriver je
trouve que l'image est d'une violence
inouïe et je pense y avait d'autres
manières de faire passer ce message
cette vidéo je la trouve qu'à barrière
even haïm alors d'abord c'est pas le
gouvernement qui l'a fait c'est un
réalisateur scénariste français dur mais
à thiès qui l'a fait qui a été aidé par
une entreprise d'effets spéciaux en
france à paris et donc il a tourné il ya
eu des images ont été tournées à paris
et lieu ensuite à kiev a fait tous ces
montages et que c'était pas en ukraine a
fait tous ces montages et il dit j'ai
voulu faire cette vidéo car j'ai voulu
que ça touche tout le monde je les fait
à paris car je suis français c'est ma
ville et donc il s'agissait d'
interpeller batoul et où les tous les
européens pour leur dire voilà ce qui se
passe chez le maire c'est la regarder
alors que certains croient tout ça en
même temps qu'il veut parler bernard
manque hélas ici je suis mitigé sur le
comportement de l1 ce qui évidemment il
défend son pays le défi c'est pas je
sais c'est pas élastique a fait ça mais
comme une menace tout le temps c'est un
réalisateur qui a tout perdu oui oui je
sais bien mais
le président de l'ukraine actuellement
qui évidemment qui est agressé as un
pays qui a été agressée on le sait je
trouve qu'ils nous menacent sans arrêt
il nous menace l'europe si vous vous
occupez pas de nous ça va vous arriver
chez savary mais chez vous déjà la
pologne la jambe
avec
nous à dire que ça nous arrivera jamais
le coc vite ce n'était pas pour nous les
attentats s'étaient pas rien qui est
pour nous mais moi cette vidéo je laime
bien parce que nous on dit à l'ukraine
bah démerdez-vous maintenant puisque
nous on fait partie de l'otan et on a
dit qu'on interviendrait par abandonner
mais
bien comme on peut on en voit des trucs
mais on laisse l'ukraine se faire
prendre par la russie donc lui peut-être
il dit peut-être qu'on sait pas où il va
s'arrêter rang de tête qui va faire
après et peut-être la garde et de la
violence ne veut pas en dit
pas que la
france j'appartiens à une troisième gars
ici parce que je suis en train de dire
mais si tu veux qu'il vous dit non
vitelli par dj vous dis que dans un
monde où les aider si vous dis que ça va
pas arriver à les locaux tu veux que
j'aille les aider mais non mais tu dois
l'indicé
si j'étais militaire et combien le diva
j'y vais mais vas-y libres à barcelone
en verve aimantation pour l'instant la
france la france et la phase aller
pandémique est en guerre pourquoi tu
vois je suis dit que ces psys exemple à
nancy ça s'appelait bassam play with
cautionne pas ce qu'on voit quelle
tunique la france n'est rien chose que
peut-être qu'on n'a jamais été très
partagée sur peter ya des gens qui sont
compétents des sudistes satio prague à
rognac et chante à 10 ans est passé par
ici il y en a d'autres qui sont d'accord
et crémants de boyer c'est très partagés
tout le monde a son avis sur cette vidéo
jean moi j'adore parce que c'est un
électrochoc voila voila et la brenta on
est touché non c'est pas nouveau
spectacle non neda touchée parce qu'on
se dit ça peut peut-être arrivé chez
mais certains fonctionnent très bien moi
je dis bravo et là on a l'impression
comme c'est à nos portes si la loi de
proximité qu'on est encore plus concerné
donc dis bravo à ce réalisateur français
ils ont été malins parce qu'ils ont
compris quelque chose qu'on écoute qu'on
apprend en école de journalisme qui
s'appelle la loi du morro km qui leur a
plu plutôt lui puis les gens qui sont
qui décède sans loin avance plus on s'en
fiche on y sent proche plus
viande ça nous met 100 morts dans un
avion dont deux français alors mr deux
français a quand même 80 du pastiche
kelly oui c'est vrai qu'on a besoin de
voir les photos à paris parce que
l'ukraine ça ne suffit pas en fait la
misère qu'on voit sur l'ukraine la
guerre en ukraine ça ne suffit pas tu
veux qu'on se sente concerné en le
voyant sur paris pour que les gens sont
encore bien sûr pourquoi les gens sur
156 ne pas être encore plus les points
en france en fait tu as besoin de ce
sens je tourne un rock sans moi le grain
ça ne suffit pas de voir je dois voir ça
tu veux le voir à paris pour réaliser
bien que ces accords avec kelly je suis
entièrement d'accord avec eni et le fait
de fictionné comme ça je vais pas dire
de s'amuser parce que c'est pas drôle
mais de fictionné d'imaginer des scènes
terribles en france qui pourrait
malheureusement arrivé je trouve cedex
d'un mauvais goût extrême et encore une
fois je pense que le fait de voir ces
images c'est un impact sur les gens les
gens savaient ce qu'ils ont fait des
maquettes vous n'êtes pas dominé ses
entretiens jamais vide en irlande dans
une génération week-end on est dans une
cité le rapport on est dans une telle
génération un traumatisé on sort du coc
vide on est dans un climat de guerre je
pensais voir des images de rallier en
guerre c'est extrêmement violent pour
les gens mais pensez vous il ya d'autres
moyens de faire passer un message là et
c'est de finir les gens on n'a pas
entendu qui daniel moreau tient moi ça
m'a profondément choqué je trouve que on
ya quand même une mobilisation
très forte on va changer en subir les
conséquences on l'est on fait des
sanctions économiques dont on va subir
les conséquences on est vraiment très
avancées en erreur d'ailleurs de
l'essence à saint junien doris leuthard
moi je trouve que je me suis vraiment
très très chaud mais parfois vous
retrouvez votre objectivement cette
vidéo c'est oui parce que vraiment il ya
une mobilisation est vraiment fort tout
le monde dans le même sens est rare même
à ce point là c'est évidemment quand on
vois moi ça me suffit excusez moi mais
de voir les images d'une maternité
bombardé en ukraine ça me suffit j'ai
pas bien ça pour être totalement ému
évidemment je vais pas prendre mon fusil
et partir au combat mais mais si je peux
aider c'est la première fois que si
j'avais un appartement l'autre jour on
en a parlé un appartement plus grand gg
pensée 1 1 peut apprendre des réfugiés
en est qu en ukraine donc voilà je crois
qu'on est tous mobilisés et là c'est
profondément choquant moi c'est presque
comme une prise d'otage de même alors du
tout s'il ya une photo aussi qui a
énormément tourné sur les réseaux dans
les médias ce week end on y voit une
fillette en armes et sucette dans la
bouche souple est fini si regardez et
cette photo a énormément fait parler
mais en fait gilles verdez c'était le
fait cccc du fait qu'en fait ça oui
alors il ya beaucoup de de fait qu'en
fait il ya des cons ce truc si on fait
par des photographes en fait c'est la
guerre de la communication
il ya énormément de fausses informations
qui sont distillées et c'est très
difficile de s'y repérer parce qu'après
que ce soit l'ukraine ou la russie s'en
servent pour intoxiquer les opinions
mondiales donc voilà oui il ya du fric
partout raison plus on peine de faire
cesser ces vidéos de paris bombardé et
encore une fois quel que soit l'auteur
de cette vidéo moi j'aime pas du tout le
ton menaçant si vous ne faites rien déjà
il ya une énorme mobilisation on nous
dit si vous ne faites rien voilà ce qui
va se passer mais c'est insupportable
ces menaces en chine y'a pleins d'envié
c'est vrai que ça fout les boules cette
taxe et mathieu n'a pas réagi là-dessus
bah non c'est moi je suis halluciné
d'abord l'uci parce que c'est guillaume
qui est à sa fait peur aux gens et
savent pas si c'est l'affect tu pense
toujours que les gens sont plus bêtes
que toi non ils en ont compris ce que
c'était une fausse vidéo et moi j'ai vu
c'était une fausse vidéo et six mois que
ça dure quarante secondes on ne dit pas
que c'est faux
c'est la vidéo début oui j'essaye pac
estime avoit l'afrique voilà après on a
eu tout à l'om et après tu peux pas les
20 secondes après des 40000 personnes
qui sont déjà mortes en ukraine sont
désolés de savoir que ça choque et
daniel dans sa soirée toi aussi tu sais
ce qu'elle veut dire cette vidéo
évidemment que va pas rentrer dans une
guerre mondiale n'a pas le choix est ce
que ça veut dire juste c'est que pour
l'instant le monde entier se couche
devant un dictateur c'est tout ce que ça
veut dire et qu'on a besoin d'une sorte
de winston churchill eu à l'époque
c'était s'était levé que ça veut dire
que savoir que sa chaussée vos soirées
c'était juste extrêmement
béchir est ce que 2 7 millions e dont
elle est très belle mais est ce que
cette vidéo vous choquer ou ce que cette
vidéo vous a poussé à la vous dire c'est
vrai qu'il faut
alors qu'est staff et
moi je m'apprêtais shalik je suis apte
en quoi il a aidé et vas-y la soif hier
dans mon pied conforme je suis triste
pour laisse crever l'ukraine parce que
comme à 10 ans ont battu un peu tu es
avec moi laissez moi parler mais l'homme
a dit mathieu on passe des tas
d'immondices troisième guerre mondiale
royale qatarie q si on bouge on est
morts l'otan a dit aux ukrainiens on va
vous mettre dans une pièce et tout
doucement on va servir suivre l'alluré
avec jusqu'à tel-aviv
parce que en plus de la vidéo c'est un
russe et un ukrainien cd mais c'est un
mec qui veut parler de l'ukraine pour
dire regardez on est foutu mais
peut-être un jour ça va vous arriver à
vous la vidéo que dans dix ans paris la
vidéo de la petite fille tu sais c'est
une vidéo qui a été prise pas c'est une
photo qui a été prise par son père avant
la guerre moi je
parle de ça là on est là à se dire oui
alors ils m'ont dérangé dans mon confort
ils m'ont montré une vidéo mais mathieu
de la dernère nous c'est la mémoire a
dit c'est moi la veille on parle de mecs
qui sont vraiment d'idée mais sur ehpad
il fut répond-t-il distributeurs c'est
la réponse que j'ai ben on le sait déjà
pas besoin de cette ville mais ça fout
moi je voudrais
que ça oui c'est bien c'est bien
celle-là je n'empêche pas loin qu'on le
sait que l'un n'empêche pas l'autre
n'ont pas jamais vous pouvez pas
admettre quand même qu'on est en train
tous tous le monde parce qu'on a peur de
la dissension laisse crever l'ukraine si
ça nous arrivait un jour à nous qu'on
nous dise paris vous allez attaquer mais
par contre on peut pas bouger parce
qu'on a peur d'un tel jeu te dit qu'on
ferait tous des vidéos vient vous aider
mais nous aider on serait tous comme des
lapins
si tu ne prends comme un chat gravité
mais si tu achètes genova tendu cette
vidéo
on a faim qu'on les a laissé crever au
dessus en attaque j'ai pas attendu cette
vidéo là je dis juste que je me mets à
la reverser craignent un nom mais je
vais vous dire ça je me mets à la place
du crédit tant que wave la guerre ça
n'empêche pas glorieux ni à la guerre et
ça
rentre alors on veut pas voir
eh bien vous faites bien de dire sert
effectivement si vous en connaissez pas
dormir puisque pardon n'est pas assez
cultivé on était donc moi je suis très
content on a effectivement d'être au
courant aujourd'hui de voir ce qui se
passe de voir qui est vraiment poutine
parce que je ne savais pas totalement un
art dont j'ai pas la culture de tous les
grands journalistes et elle me parle
beaucoup cette vidéo
mais ce qui m'énerve c'est que d'un côté
on a démobilisé partout mais on a des
mobilisations concrète on ne peut pas
dire que la mobilisation népal en france
et des drapeaux ukrainien partout on a
le gouvernement incite les français à
recevoir des réfugiés chrétiens on ne
peut pas dire qui a pas de mobilisation
et de l'autre côté on a ces démarches
pseudo bobo artistique et qu'il ya des
tensions deux femmes ça si c'est un
réalisateur qui a fait des effets
spéciaux pour imaginer des moyens
d'autres questions que je me pose est
pourquoi paris pourquoi on ne parierait
pas ce que peux tu nous amènes à fait
d'accord mais l'autre il n'a pas menacé
que paris voilà tout ça extrêmement
[Musique]
on repart vulgaire tous ces faits
extrêmement c puis tout ça est
extrêmement arbitraire et maladroit et
je trouve qu'il ya d'autres manières de
faire passer ça vient